We Can Be Heroes has been an epic success
on Netflix, but many fans have been wondering
what happened to characters like Max from
the original Sharkboy and Lavagirl movie.
And now thanks to some crazy fun fan theories,
we may well have the answer!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the top seven Sharkboy
and Lavagirl fan theories about We Can Be
Heroes.
Just before we begin, many thanks to the sponsor
of this video, Raid Shadow Legends.
We will, of course, be talking spoilers, so
take care.
One of the most popular fan theories is that
Max is actually Miracle Guy.
Given that Sharkboy and Lavagirl are now adults,
it seems plausible that Miracle Guy is what
Max could grow up to look like.
Which it could also explain how he knows about
the song that Sharkboy sang to Max in the
original movie.
"Cheer us up by singing one of those songs
you sing so well, Sharkboy?"
"Close your eyes, shut your mouth.
Dream a dream and get us out."
In fact, Miracle Guy's snarky attitude on
display here could be down to the fact the
lullaby ended up giving Max nightmares during
his adventure on Planet Drool.
Max being Miracle Guy could also explain why
he's one of the most powerful heroes in the
Heroics with a wide range of abilities at
his disposal from flying to super-strength
and agility.
Remember that in the Sharkboy and Lavagirl
movie after arriving on Planet Drool, Max
learned that he also had powers of his own.
"I have powers?"
"More than any of us."
In that movie, he was not only able to run
at super speed, but he could also conjure
objects out of thin air.
If We Can Be Heroes is another of Max's dreams,
as some fans have suggested, then it'd make
sense that he'd give himself an impressive
set of powers, as well as a starring role
in the adult super-team.
But even if the film isn't a dream, then Max
may simply have made his dreams of becoming
a powerful superhero come true in the real
world, as suggested in the original movie.
"Some dreams are so powerful, they become
real."
"So dream a better dream...
then work to make it real."
One aspect of the theory that doesn't work
so well is how conceited and attention-seeking
Miracle Guy can be.
"Just a quick selfie for my socials while
I stop this thing."
And this behaviour doesn't fit Max's personality
when he was younger, however, it is possible
that as he grew up, his character changed
and he ended up more like Miracle Guy.
Another theory about Max is that he could
be the father of Ojo, the mysterious young
girl who turns out to be the Supreme Commander
of Ogima and an alien herself!
After all, in the Sharkboy and Lavagirl movie,
Max draws characters in his dream journal
that come to life.
And likewise, in We Can Be Heroes, Ojo draws
creatures like the Squiggle monsters on her
tablet and they come alive.
And could Ojo's ability to see events that
will occur in the future be related to Max's
power to make his dreams come true,
"Everything that is or was, began with a dream."
in a similar way to how Guppy doesn't have
the exact same powers as her parents, but
versions of them.
Another fan theory that builds on the idea
of Max being Ojo's father is that, after the
events of Sharkboy and Lavagirl, Max became
the ruler of Ogima, the alien planet that
Ojo is from.
Remember, kids are the ones in charge there.
According to this theory, later adult Max
ended up marrying the alien Ms Granada, and
they had an alien daughter together who they
called Ojo.
Max then decided to send his wife and child
to Earth disguised as humans to set up the
plan for the kids of the Heroics to take over
from their parents.
On top of that, this fan theory also suggests
that Max created a clone of himself, in the
form of Miracle Guy, who he sent to earth
as well.
An interesting observation made by "Dylan
Keller" is that the superhero "Mr Positive"
that Linus was drawing at the end of the Sharkboy
and Lavagirl movie has a similar look to Miracle
Guy.
He's got a blue costume and a cape, and although
Mr Positive's logo is different to the 'H'
for Heroics on Miracle Guy's costume, there
does seem to be an overall resemblance in
their look.
It's a curious idea, but could this suggest
that Linus dreamed Miracle Guy into existence?
Some dreams are so powerful they become real.
Perhaps that's how Miracle Guy got some of
his less desirable qualities, such as when
he tried to pick a fight with Sharkboy.
Another fun theory comes from "The Hyper Monkey"
who wonders whether Max could be Wild Card's
father.
The idea comes from the fact that Wild Card
has any power he wants at his disposal.
"There's not a single power in the world he
doesn't have."
And his only difficulty is controlling that
ability and so he's never sure what he might
turn into or what power he might summon.
"Teleport!
Heat vision!"
"Now he's a toaster."
Max too was able to summon a wide array of
powers when he fought against Minus in the
Sharkboy and Lavagirl film, creating all kinds
of objects from bubbles to butterflies and
even a shower of brains.
If this fan theory were true, then we'd have
to assume that Wild Card's father, Tech-No
was actually the grown-up Max.
Although they do look quite different, like
young Max in real life, Tech-No doesn't have
any super-human abilities.
Tech-No is, however, great at building gadgets
and gizmos such as jetpacks, similar perhaps
to Max's talent and interests as a child such
as when he built Tobor.
A theory by "tarah 4" is that Marissa, Max's
crush in the Sharkboy and Lavagirl movie,
could be Missy's mother, who's no longer alive
in We Can Be Heroes.
This theory points out that next to Missy's
alarm clock is a picture of her as a baby
with her mother, and hanging over that is
a necklace,
which makes "tarah 4" think of the magical
necklace that the Ice Princess wore in the
original movie.
Although the necklace on Missy's bedside table
is different to the Crystal Heart, remember
that Marissa only got her ability to freeze
water and time when she put the Crystal Heart
necklace on;
without it she didn't have any innate superpowers.
Which fits Missy and her grandmother's conversation
about her mother not having any superpowers.
"Do you know who the greatest superhero of
them all was?
It was your mother."
"But my mother was normal, like me."
What's also intriguing about this theory is
that it implies the necklace on Missy's bedside
table could have magical powers and give her
some kind of special abilities
if she puts it on in the We Can Be Heroes
sequel that's now in development at Netflix.
I don't think that will happen but if it did,
I imagine it wouldn't be a major part of Missy's
story
as it would take away from the deliberate
choice writer-director Robert Rodriguez made
for the character without any powers to be
the one "who makes the biggest difference".
Marissa being Missy's mother leads into another
fan theory that Missy's father, Marcus Moreno
is actually Max who ended up with his crush
from the original movie.
Remember, Marissa drew a picture of Ice Girl
and Dream Boy together holding hands in the
first film.
And in the new movie when Missy's grandmother
says
without your mother, your father never would
have become someone who leads by example
could she be referring to how Marissa saved
everyone from the villain Mr Electric when
he came to the real world?
And perhaps her heroic deed is what inspired
Max to become the leader of the Heroics when
he grew up?
The same way Missy inspires the new Heroics
to bring out the best in themselves.
One problem with this fan theory, of course,
is that adult Marcus looks different to what
you'd expect an adult Max to look like,
and while people can certainly be fair-haired
as children and dark-haired as adults that
doesn't change the fact that the filmmaker
cast Latinx actors as both Marcus and Missy
but not Max.
And while we wait to see if we'll get more
OG Sharkboy and Lavagirl characters like Max
in We Can Be Heroes 2,
it's a perfect time to check out Raid: Shadow
Legends, a great game you can enjoy on both
your mobile and desktop.
There's 10 challenging dungeons, each with
a super-tough boss that requires a specific
strategy to beat.
As a movie lover, you're sure to care about
story, and Raid has you covered with 12 fully-voiced
story campaigns and 3 levels of difficulty.
Then there are 13 awesome factions you can
use to build your team of Champions, from
Dwarves to Orcs to Banner Lords and the Undead.
There are 460 Champions to collect, each totally
unique, with their own design, skills, and
strengths.
No matter what you like, Raid's got something
for you.
The game is super popular with over 200,000
clans fighting and competing right now.
Plus, there are over 25 million other players
to compete with.
There are endless possibilities and strategies
for you to decide how to play the game, and
there's never been a better time to get started.
The arena battles are one of the best parts
of Raid where you can pit your champions against
players from all over the world.
By winning medals and getting placed in the
arena tiers, you'll unlock huge rewards and
bonuses to upgrade your champions.
Raid's Clan Boss Mode is also a lot of fun
as you team up with others to take down some
of the game's most dangerous bosses.
And as your successes mount, you'll climb
up the Clan Leaderboard to earn some awesome
individual and group rewards.
And last month, Raid just released their biggest
ever update.
Yes, the Doom Tower has arrived with 120 floors,
a bunch of secret challenge rooms, and 12
tough new bosses to take on.
It's a perfect moment to start playing and
here's the best part:
If you sign up today you'll get a stack of
free goodies and a super special Champion
called Bulwark.
He's an extra-powerful dwarf who'll get you
off to a great start in the tower.
So, hit the special link in the description
below to download the game.
Every new player will get an awesome pack
of bonuses completely free, including Void
Champion Bulwark, an XP booster, Energy Refills,
and an Ancient Shard.
You'll find all this free treasure in your
inbox here.
The offer runs for the next 30 days only,
so grab these awesome freebies right now by
hitting the links below!
Now, which of these We Can Be Heroes theories
would you like to be true?
And what would you like to see in the next
movie?
Leave your thoughts and theories in the comments
below!
If you enjoyed this do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it!
And if you want to discover more hidden secrets
and clues to everything you missed in the
movie's big twist ending, tap here to watch
my We Can Be Heroes Twisted Truth video.
Or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!